they're the migrants from Central
America that is a real challenge it is
an emergency drug trafficking the
profits from that trafficking often in
the form of guns 19 to 20 billion that's
right we trade 1 million dollars a
minute with Mexico
per minute per minute what's the
difference between Mexico versus China
to you they are doing this unfairly
they're doing it with some stolen
technology why is the President of
Mexico being paid a hundred million
dollars by El Chapo you'd have to have
some evidence what's the long-term
solution for the folks of Venezuela it's
a horrible situation three and a half
million refugees lack of medical care
you think that would cause him to say
okay I give up I don't see another
solution you know we're not everybody's
mother but if there is domestic violence
and it's getting pretty ugly I'm sorry I
got to get a mic what Maduro is doing to
some of his people these are young kids
that are eating rotting meat I don't
think we should get militarily involved
what are your thoughts would how a is
gonna affect the future of economy and
job placement some jobs are gonna be
completely eliminated there's many many
cemeteries filled with companies like
blockbuster Kmart and many other ones
that are buried there
[Music]
by yesterday's Tony Wayne former
ambassador to Argentina as well as
former US ambassador to Mexico
Tony thanks for being a guest on by
tainment great to be with you Patrick
yes good to have you so Tony as somebody
who was a former ambassador yourself to
Mexico what is your take on all these
things that's going on with US and
Mexico tariffs we're now gonna do a
tariff so we're gonna do tariffs what
are your thoughts on that well it's an
opportunity to learn how important
Mexico is the United States I mean
that's one thing that strikes you when
you've been when I've been following
this for the past couple of years we
trade 1 million dollars a minute with
Mexico 4 minutes per minute we have a
million crossings of the border every
day we have a relationship across that
2,000 mile border that means that Mexico
is the country that touches the lives of
more Americans than any other country
every day each day and people don't
really understand that until you get
into a crisis and then you see how much
we need to work together to solve the
problems that are there and to maintain
all the important benefits we're getting
in this relationship so what is your
interpretation of what President Donald
Trump's challenge is with the border
well there are a couple different
challenges that the border cross of
course they're the migrants that's from
Central America been coming that is a
real challenge it is an emergency
they've started coming in family units
at unprecedented numbers and they
surprised everybody by how many are
coming short now we can talk about the
reasons for that but we do need to have
a better management of it and we just
can't absorb that many neither can
Mexico which is part of the reason why
they're coming through they've
overwhelmed their capacity also secondly
we have a problem of the drug
trafficking that does take place across
the border and we have the profits from
that trafficking that go back to Mexico
often in the form of guns that they
bought to take
back to be used by the cartels in Mexico
the profits of the trafficking that they
do in us they get the money from here
and that goes back to Mexico I'm saying
that does it so they the estimates are
they make 19 to 29 30 billion dollars a
year selling those drugs in the United
States then a lot of that goes back to
Mexico
to the cartels to fuel their operations
so 19 to 20 billion that's right and it
goes back to Mexico and it goes back to
Mexico and so one of the challenges is
handling the illicit commerce in both
directions and that means you have to go
after supply for sure but you have to go
after demand also got it you have to try
and bring that demand down in the United
States and that's what would be a big
help to us because we have all these
addiction deaths in the United States
which we don't want
we've got to do that and then in Mexico
all this money fuels the violence that
they've been plagued by the rising
homicides in that country so so the
tariffs that President Trump puts on
Mexico that was you know taking out
fairly quickly didn't last a long time
it lasted I think the lifespan of the
tariffs I don't even know if didn't even
go and didn't go into effect so do you
think the intention of wanted to have a
tariff was to say cuz you know on the
campaign he said mexica is gonna pay for
the wall do you think it's his way of
saying Mexico paid for the wall or do
you think it's more of trying to focus
on protecting the border ask in Mexico
what can you do to fix the immigration
problem we'll come in here what do you
think yourself I think he was trying to
get Mexico's attention to be better at
helping fix the number of migrants
headed north ok so it's very simple you
don't think you don't read into it
thinking there's anything more than that
well that's why I think he did that now
we previously also said I'm gonna shut
the border down and sometimes in some of
his statements he's linked it to drug
trafficking also but basically he was
trying to get attention I believe this
is getting out of hand let's fix it now
the problem with that tactic is said he
also panics a lot of American
businessmen and a lot of American
consumers because we are so dependent on
we are building things together I mean
half of all our trade with Mexico are
intermediate goods they go into a final
product either in the United States or
Mexico and then the other half are final
things but they're consumed in both
countries so if you put those if you
actually put those tariffs on you would
be taxing US businesses and US consumers
as well as hurting Mexicans so everybody
would really be paying the price so the
bottom line is it's very good that we
did not go on that path but you still
have a lot of business people who are
very worried about the unpredictability
of this situation and you know since you
produce and talk to talk with
entrepreneurs all the time what they
crave is knowing the rules knowing the
situation so they can make their
planning they can invest they can take
their innovative steps if they want to
but they're not going to get knocked
around my changes in government rules
yes it's funny to say that we were
talking to a friend of mine who runs the
restaurant it's a very good sized
restaurant they do 20 million years it's
not a small restaurant and I said how
much is this tariff this conflict were
happened with us-mexico affecting you he
says a lot I said tell me more tell me
what you mean about this as tomatoes
onions you started getting into this is
we feel the pain he says because five
pennies or even two pennies felt on
20,000 pounds a month that that can end
up being money so it's interesting you
say that's I know the entrepreneurs are
affected by it so how different is our
relationship with Mexico that we had a
little bit of a challenge with different
than the relationship we have with China
because there's trade issues going both
places what's the difference between
Mexico versus China - well first I think
Canada and Mexico are have been our
number one in number three export
markets China's number two shine us a
Mexico in Canada have been number one
and number two because they're neighbors
they're real and then China is right
there in between got it now Mexico has
actually become number one this year
because of the problems with China but
the difference there there are a couple
differences one is we build things with
Canada
go we don't do that with China so for
example a car coming back from Mexico
that looks like a Mexican car really 40%
of that car is American product American
input the car was coming in from China
be 4% might be American product so
there's a real difference and then if it
was Canada 25 percent or 20 percent so
the difference is we make things
together with our neighbors we don't do
that with China the other thing is we
don't have the problem with intellectual
property theft that that we have with
China with our two neighbors they
respect our intellectual property we've
had these rules under the the NAFTA
trade agreement since the early 1990s
we worked we've had problems but we've
worked them through we have a really
smooth relationship and the private
sector has built these big networks of
trade for lettuce avocados and other
things but for cars for building things
together that's different with China
there we do have in some of the high
tech areas and iPhones and other things
we do have that kind of relationship but
more of that is put together with
Chinese products the intellectual
property is us intellectual property but
that's where you get into the problem of
China not respecting intellectual
property stealing it right trying to
make it turning into its own industry
that's turning it into a more of a
predatory relationship so it sounds like
you are for what President Trump is
doing to China right now to gut recut a
new deal on the tariffs whether it has
to do with us not having to share our
intellectual property with them due to
their new made in China 25 plan that
they have it sounds like you're almost
for what he's doing
well I'm surely for dealing forcefully
with the Chinese or you are for dealing
forcefully with the gun to get there to
get them to pay attention to change
their practices but what you have to do
is you've got to balance that very
carefully because there's a lot of pain
that comes with this at the same time
our farmers for example lost a lot of
markets and the combination of having
disputes with Canada Mexico and
together hurt the farmers of the United
States and Midwest
tremendously those were their biggest
debt record-breaking bankruptcies that
we have an at for over a decade that's
right you have to measure the tools
you're going to use but the costs of
using those tools what does that mean
that means I probably would not have put
terrorists as as large sheriff's I would
have looked for other ways do increased
pressure I would have rallied other
trading partners with to join us in
pressuring China how would you do that
well I would do it by working with them
to get them and show them what they're
losing to I would have explored what are
you willing to do we're willing to up
these tariffs do this are you willing to
do something similar to increase the
pressures I would have explored that but
is it something they don't want to do
the coalition what we haven't we haven't
really forcefully explored that I think
we've gone about this as the US versus
China now you can do that but there are
costs to do we know that that's all I'm
saying what's the worst thing that can
happen so so take us to the worst place
so we're talking worst place on what
could happen between the US and China
relationship when it comes down to trade
well the worst place is that we pull
down a new shade not quite an Iron
Curtain but a trade curtain where our
trade goes way down we have different
partners in the rest of the world we
trade with those partners but it's no
longer part of it of a free-flowing
unified market and you don't get the
benefits of that more free and fair
trade and so that would be I think the
worst outcome you sort of move into two
different spheres of influence the best
outcome would be we get to an
understanding of what the the best
practices are for trade and you know we
don't like each other wonderfully maybe
we disagree on democracy other practices
but we still have a strong interaction
between our economies that builds on the
strengths of each of each economy do you
think it's really gonna be a deal where
it's gonna be 50/50 we're both benefits
from the each other evenly
or do you think right now you know
president Trump's trying to strike a
deal that's more benefiting us versus it
is China well I'm sure he's trying to
get the best deal he can which means
he'd like to get more benefit for the US
I don't know where it's gonna come out
really but what I do know is the worst
outcome would be that we don't solve the
problems we sort of divide the world up
and we're competing all around the world
but we're not solving the differences
between us and one of the problems are
we are going to have some serious
differences on some military geostrategy
Oh strategic issues in the South China
Sea we're going to have differences over
our approach to democracy it's easier to
solve some of those problems if you're
not fighting about everything so if we
can get to some understandings on the
international commerce that are mutually
beneficial I mean we'll have to figure
out it won't be clear right away this is
49 you know 50 to 51 or is it 30 70
we'll see over time but if we can get to
a an understanding and start working
that we will see who's coming out here
how's it working and then we can turn
our attention to other issues versus
just on fighting about all the issues
how much are you following the huawei
scandal with the maenge in Canada and
Wren are you following the 5g battle
between US US and China so how do you
feel about the fact that when he signed
the executive order no US company can do
business with Huawei and then Google
comes out it cut the contract for their
operating system in our Huawei's project
and that they're gonna lose 30 to 40
percent of revenues how much you think
the fear of China getting 5g before us
is the motivation behind us pushing
China with their tariffs do you see that
as possibly being one of the reasons I
don't think that's the main reason for
pushing the tariffs but I think it is
part of the calculation and I think what
people saw was China had laid out this
very ambitious plan over the next decade
to build their high-tech capacity
they're moving ahead of us with
distributing 5g technology around
world and the idea was they are doing
this unfairly they're doing it was some
stolen technology with some government
subsidies and so people indeed are quite
worried and they're worried about the
the fact that Chinese companies have to
cooperate with their government on
intelligence matters and so thus they're
worried that Huawei systems can be
penetrated by the Chinese government
when they're deployed around the world
now all those things have to be verified
they have to be looked through and all
of our partners haven't accepted that
and that's part of the debate that's
going on internationally when we go
other places and don't and say don't buy
kwame people say why not we give our
argument they said well show me show me
this and show me how the Chinese are
using this and so this is it's not clear
where this is going to come out yet but
clearly the US government is as as you
said it's become very worried about blow
away and has launched a strong effort
not just China US but internationally
I wonder what's gonna happen I mean I
wonder okay so let's just say we strike
up a deal and it's a great deal what is
a great deal for us if we were able to
get something with China in your opinion
well in my opinion it would be a
verifiable deal on intellectual property
rights it would look at state subsidies
for companies that compete
internationally and would have a
regulation of that it would have the the
right to a dispute settlement mechanism
with the right to take retaliatory
action if if that settlement results in
sociation complain is right you know it
would be a big set of issues it would
not what it would not be is we're going
to buy fifty thousand more tons of soil
mixed years that would be good but we
what you need are institutional fixes
that deal with the bad practices not
just promises of mine
more things for irritated yeah again I'm
really curious what's gonna happen with
this because it's been going on and it
doesn't seem like either side is giving
in so we'll see how that's gonna end up
talking about you as an ambassador of
Mexico when you were there did you did
you have any direct dealings I would
assume you did with pena nieto yes and
so president president president Pena
Nieto I read an article one time about
you know El Chapo saying that New York
Times article matter of fact I think it
was that he got a hundred million
dollars when you know El Chapo was doing
what he was doing
how was he held accountable if that is
verified that that happened what what do
you or what do we is that a worry for
market to say why is the President of
Mexico being paid a hundred million
dollars by El Chapo who we know you're
talking about the 19 billion dollars of
drug trafficking back in for and it's
not just cocaine he's doing a lot of
different drugs that you're dealing with
does that concern you at all and if yes
what are the repercussions to him for
being held accountable for that well yes
it is great of great concern because we
know there is corruption we know these
drug groups by buy a lot of officials
they threaten them and pay them and it
makes it very very hard to go after
these organizations in Mexico when
that's happening now I don't know
anything about a particular bribe to the
president except I saw that allegation
but we do know that money was flowing to
officials and so what this makes really
important is that you have an effective
and independent justice system that can
investigate these things bring people to
trial that has not been particularly the
case in Mexico their justice system
worked slowly there have not been big
corruption cases that have been brought
that's one of the promises of the new
President Andres Manuel Lopez Obrador
that he's going to really go after
corruption they've announced a few new
cases of corruption but what you really
have to have our big high-level
officials being held accountable if
there is indeed evidence they
got payments from drug groups or from
others for public contracts or other
things who holds them accountable us us
has somebody that's trying to have a
trade relationship with them wars in
Mexico's government holding them
accountable it ultimately has to be
Mexico's government but if if the money
or if there's comes the US or if there's
property purchased in the US then the
United States can take action against
that money from corruption and we have
in fact brought cases against governor's
and others in Mexico who have
transferred questionable funds let's say
into real estate in the United States
for example so that we could if they do
if they do that if it passes through our
system we have authority to go after it
so Pena Nieto president former president
of Mixel Pena Nieto bicep property in us
and we feel a strong urge to one
investigating because we think he was
paid off by El Chapo then we could we
we'd have to have more than the urge
we'd have to have some evidence that he
actually got paid off but we have done
that with other Mexican officials we
have done that because we have gotten me
the evidence and testimonies in some
cases of witnesses who helped facilitate
the money transfers let me ask you what
do you think about whistleblowers are
they good for the world are they good
for the country I think they are good
for the world
I think we do need to have people are
willing to speak up and we do need to
protect them when they speak up and
their evidence is is proven to be good
evidence you know not just trying to
retaliate against somebody I think it is
valuable so you think we can links what
they do is good for the world do you
think it's good for us well in a sense
what I'd say is I wouldn't quite call
that whistleblowing I would say that's
just putting all sorts of stuff out
there that wasn't public and making a
public without any thinking through one
of the effects of that going to be what
I think of a whistleblower is somebody
that comes into a prosecutor and says
look this bad thing is going on here's
some evidence and I'm willing to testify
about it that's not going out to the
public and just saying
here all these secret files that we
don't think there should be any secret
activities going on so we're gonna
publish them that's a different thing
got it so you're for whistleblowers
you're not for WikiLeaks on what they're
doing yes you think they're gonna slow
down at all I think it it is slowing it
down because people are they're getting
blowback people are saying well this is
too much why are you doing this you know
are you just trying to destroy and not
necessarily bad things now it is one
thing to find a scandal to find
corruption to find something the illegal
going on publicizing that it's another
thing just a publicized thing is because
what's the difference what's the
difference when you're breaking a law
you're doing something you're breaking
up like emails if they're well besides
in emails if they're publicizing the
communication with me and somebody else
and it has to do with the government and
I did something that I broke the law is
that consider whistleblowing is that
considered sharing information that
could potentially hurt the country well
you'd have to look at the specifics I
think of what we shared and what was
what what laws were being broken and
what you would do it yeah I'm asking
that question because I wonder how much
that's going to going on go on in the
next election that we have yeah I wonder
because you know I think this is going
to be a very ugly one that's coming up
and I think moving forward it's going to
get uglier and uglier I don't think it's
gonna get any more diplomatic and oh I
respect my opponents but this is what I
believe in I don't think we're in that
era no I think you're right that
socially we're redefining what is
privacy what should be private what
needs to be protected what shouldn't be
protected what's fair play to bring up
and I think that is changing we've seen
it change over this last decade it's
going to change some more and I think
you're getting you're getting both some
reaction to too much of that but we
haven't really defined what's what are
the new social norms here and we have
all these actors from all over the world
intervening everywhere they're not gonna
stop though and they're not going to
stop they're not right so they're just
gonna get bigger and bigger and so hard
to catch them though because it's so
it's it's it's massive you're not
dealing with three or four you're
dealing with so many of them it's gonna
be fine it's gonna be
you know when you pay to watch a good
fight you know a good boxing fight I
think if they put the debates on
pay-per-view I think it would sell so
much if they did at this time whoever
it's gonna be I mean if it's gonna be
burned you're biting or whatever first
Elizabeth Warren that comes up to go up
against Trump it will be very
entertaining sino the last one was
Venezuela are you do you have any
opinions about what's going on with
Venezuela on what the long-term
solutions would be for the folks of
Venezuela I know a lot of friends from
Venice all in our company we have a lot
of people that are Venezuelans that work
I myself did a video on Venezuela and
it's a concern when you see how they
don't have vitamins they don't have food
they're going through a really tough
times and a lot of them are leaving to
Colombia or Peru what is the long-term
solution for us to address someone like
Maduro who is not willing to work to
allow the free election taking place
what's the long-term solution for the
folks of Venezuela well you're you're
exactly right that it's a horrible
situation three and a half million
refugees a lot of malnutrition in the
country lack of medical care horrible
situation on the other hand nobody is
willing to step forward and say there's
a military solution here and part of
that is there's part of it what
justifies intervening in another country
part of him is recognition he still has
a lot of support not just from the
military but from the militias the
chavista militias that are armed in that
country so the solution that people are
trying to pursue I think is in in
principle right which is you find ways
to increase the pressure on them and you
try to reduce the resources they have
available to pay for what they're doing
in their government and that you get to
a situation where either they decide
they're going to leave or they're happy
to negotiate a way to leave and a
transition maybe to an internationally
supervised election but I don't think
this is going to happen quickly it is
going to be
necessary to have a constant effort to
look at ways by the regional countries
by other international countries to
increase that pressure and that probably
means we get back to China here it
probably means working China working
Russia working Cuba to get them to stop
buying Venezuelan petroleum to increase
that pressure do you think that would
cause him to say okay I give up I think
it would make it a lot harder for them
to run the country because they would
have less income to actually pay their
soldiers their militia and that I think
would open the door I don't see another
solution
what's another what what do you see well
I mean you know the whole thing goes
where it's like you know we're not
everybody's mother we're not here to
take care of everybody we should say out
of people's business it's like hey if
people are going through marital issues
just kind of leave them alone let the
husband and wife resolve but if there is
domestic violence and it's getting
pretty ugly and you know it and you see
it and you hear about it
should you get them on say Johnny listen
man if you hit her I'm sorry I got to
get a mic I just natural instinct it's
kind of like what Maduro is doing to
some of his people it's a different form
of hitting them because they're not
being feted these are young kids that
are eating rotten meat so you sit and
wondering should we get involved and be
a little bit more proactive about this
or should we just kind of sit in the
sidelines and say it's Venezuela's
problem it's central it's South
America's problem that then figure it
out it's not our problem maybe somebody
that's coming out there gentlemen that's
currently in Colombia cuido I believe
maybe he's gonna do something about it
but let their election take place for
itself so do you think we should get
involved and do something about it
whether it's military or any other kind
of support I don't think we should get
militarily involved I think that it
would take so much force and be such a
long intervention that it wouldn't have
the support of the American people but I
do think we need to remain economically
involved with diplomacy with more
sanctions with trying to cut off those
resources and finding new ways to cut
off those resources they're short and we
have to do it with others we have to
have
an international coalition that gets
stronger and stronger you're still
billing in China we need Cuba we need
these guys to work to spit out well we
need to figure ways to get them to stop
supporting that regime it's going to be
hard but it would be very hard to
militarily intervene in that country
yeah it's a it's a it's like it's almost
where it's a Pablo except he runs the
country yeah Pablo that's running the
country so it's a not the usual dynamic
were used to in maybe we are used to a
little bit of it but we didn't do much
about it back then anyway so last but
not least you got a project where you're
working on future a workforce with AI
and you see a lot of people concerned
about what AI could do and how jobs are
changing you know we have to reposition
ourselves
what are your thoughts would how ai is
going to affect the future of our
economy and job placement well I think
probably we're gonna see about 30% on
average everybody's job change over the
next five to ten years some jobs are
going to be completely eliminated some
new ones are going to be created and
then others are going to be reinvented
and so if we don't get smarter about the
mix of private sector business models
education and education coming into the
workforce and while you're in the
workforce and then government policies
that help support that we're going to
suffer some of the same problems we've
seen over this first 15 years or so of
this decade with a lot of people feeling
left behind getting pushed out of the
workforce being politically disgruntled
we need to get ahead of it right now
one recent study found that the same
parts of the country that got hit by the
first decade of job losses are going to
be hit again when AI comes in it's going
to be these traditional manufacturing
areas on average they're going to be hit
harder so unless we change
approach we're going to relive that same
kind of pain so what I've been working
on are a number of specific ideas of how
governments the education sector and
private companies can start working
nationally at state levels and then
locally to really train people as part
of just the way you do business so for
all the entrepreneurs and business
people watching your channel it's
building into their model I'm just gonna
have to count for Spain spending money
to invest in my human capital to give
them retraining when we get new
technologies sometimes it might be a
week sometimes it might be a month
depends on the business and I'm going to
have to be supportive of working with
that local community college or
university that they actually give the
courses have been going to make people
good workers for me they can't just do
English literature as important as that
is or history or those straight business
classes they really have to know what
kind of technology is coming through
where visits aren't they slow aren't
colleges slow to adapt with what's
needed to teach there are if there's a
criticism of colleges if there's skill
set that stated today we're not gonna
get it as a class for four years that's
right so that's why we what I think is
we have to establish these these active
interactive councils between government
education and business in different
localities is something that can be done
regionally to be talking about this on a
regular basis so people are reinforcing
the need to change so they could do it
more quickly and it's the same way for
business you know business traditionally
if I need somebody new I'll hire that
person new and if these people don't
have the skills thank you for your
service I think that's gonna have to
change in a sense as it already has in
Germany and Japan they build that into
their business model that sure some
people leave but they're really training
their workers along the way so when that
new technology comes in when those
robots come in when the machine learning
starts they they train those workers and
that's just part of the expense of doing
business it's being more competitive to
do that yeah it's going to be
again with a I I think private sector is
going to be
dosoo adapt and adjust quickly we'll
have the edge but I also read a lot of
people say experts say that a is not
gonna have a big effect for a long time
and when it does you know those who
adjust and adapt quickly will benefit
from it those who don't our tech are
gonna take a hit but it's not gonna be
the next 5-10 years there are some
experts that are saying 30 40 years is
when it's really gonna happen but nobody
knows we're gonna see what's going to
happen now there are a number of studies
the World Economic Forum Accenture you
know a number of the other manpower
groups and stuff look at it and they say
now you're really gonna start feeling it
and over the next five and ten years so
you if you're smart you just start
changing your system now and you get
ready well I think it's better to
anticipate it coming right I think it's
smarter to anticipate it coming so
you're not surprised the last thing you
wanted businesses to be surprised you
can seen a lot of companies do that and
there's many many cemeteries filled with
companies like blockbuster Kmart and
many other ones that are buried there so
some of the areas for example you think
well some of it is on-the-job learning
apprenticeship but there are things like
credentials like where you're gonna hire
somebody what does that credential mean
so there are a lot of things you can do
to make those credentials more have more
confidence in them to be shared more
widely you can have data of the markets
that's more transparent and more readily
available for all the businesses so they
know cheer over in New England they have
an excess of these engineers that we
need let's get let's reach out there and
get them there things you can
government's can do to make that data
more available so there are a whole
bunch of things you can do to make this
a smoother process and that's what we're
looking I think the wind either got
excited or got upset at your feedback
about AI but we're gonna find that next
five to ten years what happens I want to
hear from you whatever thoughts you have
about today's interview with Tony Wayne
whether we talked about Mexico Venezuela
China tariffs AI any of that stuff want
to hear your thoughts below if you
haven't subscribed to the channel do so
Tony thank you so much for being a guest
on value tainment a pleasure Brazilian
journey thank you
you